this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us america ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we talk about your careers your money
and your life open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
big day here at ramsey launch day
it's here for another
number one best-selling book that's my
prediction i like those predictions uh
from paycheck to purpose hit the streets
today by ken coleman and we've been
working on pre-selling this for a couple
of months now letting you guys know
about it it is now officially available
if you've already purchased one it is in
the mail baby
we are shipping it that direction so um
get ready here we go i mean this is cool
the book is from paycheck to purpose the
clear path
to doing
work
you love
now here's the thing
what ken has put his finger on and what
he does with the ken coleman show and
the website kingcoleman.com
is to keep you from getting stuck in the
resume pile
showing you how not to do that but more
importantly when you do make a move make
it strategically a lot of you are
looking at making a move right now yeah
that you do it strategically
so that you don't end up in a worse
situation from toxicity or lack of
purpose i hate my job don't spend your
whole life i hate my job yeah paycheck
from paycheck to purpose you need to get
a paycheck and you ought to get it doing
something that has purpose that's it
that's why we titled it that because we
want people to go from the universal
view of work that i just work to live of
course you've got to have a paycheck and
provision we want you to have a great
paycheck but we know that everybody dave
at some point in their life asked the
question what should i do with my life
why am i here and we don't have to teach
ourselves to do that just like you have
to teach a toddler to take a toy or to
say no why is that
well because we are souls and we long to
make a difference and so what we're
doing in this book
through a very practical seven stage
process think of it as climbing to your
professional pinnacle where you're
making the income that you want you got
that big shovel you're out of debt
you're giving yourself away it's the
seventh stage and it
it really works it beautifully with the
seven baby steps this idea of live like
no one else so that later you can give
like no one else well what if you worked
like no one else
or very few where you showed up and you
were doing something you were good at
hello you actually
enjoyed doing the work and then the
results of the work
make you feel
tremendously significant at the end of
the day because you go there's a
connection to that and we talk about
that here at ramsey solutions all the
time
work that matters because in this place
we're crusaders to give people hope and
i want to give people hope as it relates
to the thing they spend more time doing
in their life than anything else besides
family time and sleeping it's work well
what if there was purpose in your work
what if
you could do something that you were
created to do and fill
that void that so many people never get
filled and make a great paycheck that's
what the book is it's tremendously
practical if you're just going all right
i know what i want to do ken i got that
part
how do i level up how do i keep moving
up because we all want to be promoted
well we cover that we cover the basics
how do i answer that question what
should i do with my life can i got that
part i just don't know how to get there
well we talk about that too
get clear get qualified get connected
get started get promoted get the dream
job
give yourself away those are the seven
stages and here's what's beautiful dave
as you know you and i are both in the
dream job you're further along than me
but those stages repeat themselves
because when we get to the top of the
mountain folks
the view changes we've been looking up
the whole time when we get to the top we
begin to look out and in this book the
final chapter dave you know um you know
i write about the great explorer who
gets to the top of mount everest
and he says to a sherpa sherpa climbing
partner he says or after they've taken
pictures and they've put a few things at
the top of the mountain mementos he sees
another mountain range and he says
that's the one i want to climb
and that's the same thing we as humans
are humans who are driven by progress
uh to to make a contribution and so we
don't just sit in our hammock and drink
sun tea when we get to the dream job the
view changes we look i mean the
commercial wasn't right it's not right
it turns out that that doers
they they have another dream yeah
hammocks aren't usually they're nice for
a season it's okay to rest and
recuperate it's why we have weekends
right
recreate
yeah
so from paycheck to purpose yeah uh
ramsay's
next ramsey publishing's next number one
best seller comes out today yeah you can
pick it up on in bookstores and target
that fine french store you can go to um
uh
amazon and you can certainly go to
ramseysolutions.com
and we've got them here and we'll get it
right out to you no delay in the
shipping at all it'll go out the day out
the door immediately if not sooner
so good stuff good stuff very very cool
so i went over today uh we have 15 new
people started ramsey money oh yeah so
that we do two days of
onboarding and i always go in i try to
go in if i can second morning and just
listen to what's going on and it was
really interesting hearing them go
around the room after they've been here
one day
and a couple of developers sitting in
there coding guys top top shelf i mean
senior developer level uh
and they're like oh so refreshing
they're just so refreshing to get to do
my craft
in a situation where
what the code i'm writing is helping
people change their lives yes the code
i'm writing matters
it's not just in a you know in the
basement of some
machine
that's just cranking out and we don't
work 80 hours a week which is the coders
if you don't know out there developers
web world they just work they should
work the snot out corporate america
burns them up and so they work 80 90
hours a week most places here we work 40
hours a week we go home we actually see
our families and stuff like that we do
yes yeah but it was just it was cool to
hear those guys
living out what your book is talking
about exactly right that they found a
way that that that and these are
major oh serious positions
senior
senior devs are big time and um
can work anywhere they want to work in
the world right now because their demand
is so high yeah and uh but just they
just
it was just a sigh yes just a release of
oxygen
well the reason feels so good is they
realize that now passion and mission
are coming into the picture when they
walk in the workplace before it was just
talent only they're very talented people
a lot of these people dave talk about
come to us from big name companies we're
talking top top top talent here but
talent isn't enough
because what we as human beings long for
is a connection to the work we want to
actually love the craft you know you and
i both love history we love craftsman
you know when i was a kid we would go to
all these uh historic presidential homes
and things of that nature and i would
watch blacksmiths and silversmiths do
their thing these are craftsmen they
love the craft itself that's passion but
it's more about what are you producing
and these people that are coding they're
producing hope on the other end
practical steps to give people freedom
that's mission as versus the salt mines
of the developer world it's making a
rich guy
right that's right produce code
not here baby i love it
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
welcome to the ramsey show ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we take your calls about your life
your money your career on launch day for
ken's new book from paycheck
to purpose the clear path to doing work
you love going to start off with
jennifer in los angeles hi jennifer
welcome to the ramsey show
hello thank you for taking my call sure
what's up
okay so i am planning on moving out of
state from i'm from bakersfield actually
moving out of state for work and i have
a home here i'm on baby step six working
on paying this house off
um
the market's really high
right now um so i'm if i sell my house i
don't know where i should park my equity
or if it's a good idea to just rent my
house out um because when i do move i
will be renting for a year until i
figure out where i actually want to live
so that's my question cool
so uh why are you moving you're getting
a new job where
well
i'm a nurse and there's just a lot of
restrictions out here i've wanted to
leave the state of california for a very
long time and um
i spent the last eight months working
out in texas and i really enjoyed it
so so texas here we come huh
possibly or tennessee we are somewhere
between there we hear that story a lot
yeah we we are in tennessee we hear it a
lot yeah so it's very cool well good uh
well what i would do if i woke up in
your shoes which is by the way how i
answer questions here is if i knowing
what i know if i woke up just like you
what would i do i would sell the house
okay okay a lot of reasons the reason is
um number one like you said the market's
hot
and it's a possible high point to i
don't know it probably is going to go
higher
long term but right now you can get
really really good money out of it you
can sell it really easily
and you're going to pay no income tax on
the growth
okay did you make are you going to make
a profit of more than 250 000 no uh
it'll be close to i think after closing
costs and everything around 100 000.
okay then you'll make all of that
hundred without any taxes on it single
person married filing jointly is 500 000
you can make on your home uh mary a
single person can make up to 250
profit on your home over what you paid
for it
and uh with no taxes at all and i would
take that and i would put it in a money
market account
move to texas tennessee wherever it is
start my nursing career once you decide
you're going to put down roots in that
location
then i would start looking at purchasing
but long distance landlording is not a
good plan
uh it's very difficult it's uh i always
laugh and i got a bunch of real estate i
love real estate but long distance
landlording is always a good way to get
somebody to change their harley oil in
your living room
and so it's many
so many market accounts and not like a
mutual fund unless you're going to leave
it alone five years i wouldn't use a
mutual fund
but i i think you're going to move
somewhere and a year from now you're
going to start getting an itch to buy
if you've decided to stay in that city
okay does that sound right to you
yes it does now i have one more question
from that would if i because i'm
considering going and getting my
master's degree and i don't
i'm sorry why
yeah just to um ex like i guess grow my
options as far as nursing goes um
because i would like to get into like
management leadership administration
okay that's a good way
good well i would use some of this money
to pay for that then and let me just
tell you master's degrees are priced all
over the map do not overpay for this
little two-year degree
absolutely i just plan not to i plan
this in as little as possible because
where you went to school will not
determine whether you get hired
okay no one hires people based on famous
colleges that's absolute bs put out by
famous colleges yeah
yes jennifer i'd ask are you positive
that you need a master's to get those
leadership positions
i'm not positive but i feel like them i
feel like i've been trying to like apply
because i've been a nurse for a lot
almost 12 years and i want to get out of
bedside nursing and
i just it seems like they want that
degree sure well again
it's a great why but i want you to go
from i feel like it seems like to i
absolutely know that there's a higher
percentage chance much higher percentage
chance if i have it versus not and the
reason i say this is because you have an
opportunity here to get in as you move
into a new place you've got 12 years
experience very talented and you express
the desire to lead and begin to lead up
and show leadership that you're leading
being that 360 degree leader as our
friend john maxwell wrote a book on um i
i would just look into that and if it's
the best way
then then do it if it's the only way do
it if it's not either one of those two
then uh hustle save yourself some time
and money on that man
sometimes people have an illusion that a
degree is necessary for something when
it's not
that's ken's point and so really dig
into it start talking to people in the
role that you want to be in and find out
if they how many of them actually have
master's degrees and how much of a
barrier it is to not have one
so um because sometimes it's just like i
don't feel secure i don't feel confident
and so i'm going to get this degree and
that's going to make me confident not
really
you hire a lot of leaders dave we'll
just put this to the test i don't
master's degree is nice you respect it
but that doesn't
factor into the decision
not not at all i mean two percent five
percent whatever i mean i mean a
master's in business is a great very mba
is a great it's a great degree it's a
good field to study
but and we've got some of them on the
team um and they're they're smart and
they're good it's all great but i'd hire
them for that i heard them because i
could see in their eyes and in their
mannerisms and in the interview process
that they were going to be able to lead
people yeah
and that is usually not taught in the
classroom by the way
so um but you've got to get that built
out keith is with us in philadelphia hi
keith welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking my call sure
um i had a hsa question um i just wanted
to know if i should open one up this
year uh
i um i already maxed out my raw 401k i
maxed out the uh brawls ira
and
but i'm only i'm only able to do that
because
i've been working a lot of overtime at
my job so
when i go back to say that over time
dies out
uh
i just wanted to know do i need an extra
retirement savings vehicle
or should i just
stick with the 401k and ira stick with
the 401k and the ira the hsa is fine
to use for saving money long term i've
used mine that way but that's way down
the road of stuff you worry about the
hsa is a health savings account it has
it's tied to your health insurance
program are you currently in a high
deductible plan that allows an hsa
no i'm not in the plan but because it's
open season i was you could jump over
into that plan are you in a ppo now yes
yes okay how much does it save you a
month on the insurance to go to the hsa
well i know the bi-weekly premiums would
be maybe
20 30 less a paycheck okay so like 60
bucks
and so what we're talking six seven
hundred bucks a year say less expensive
how much greater is the deductible
um that i don't know i rarely see your
doctor no it doesn't matter you need to
know what the deductible is
okay because if you've got a 200
deductible now and you're going to a 5
000 deductible for a 600 savings that
might not be a plan
the hsa works really really good for
people like you that are very healthy or
for people that are chronically ill and
always blowing through their uh
deductible because it has a most of them
have a hundred percent after you blow
through the deductible
and so there's no copay
i don't know what yours is but i have an
hsa on me we offer both at my company to
my team and about 90 percent of the team
is on the hsa because it's cheaper
premiums and if you choose to you can
save money over there i'm less concerned
with you saving money over there than i
am just getting the right health
insurance in place and not paying too
much but if you can cover that high
deductible with your emergency fund and
save six seven hundred bucks a year by
moving over to that hsa while it's open
season i would look at doing that dude
if you're healthy and things are going
well but i would not do it because of
the savings element the savings elements
just some extra goodies
[Applause]
i do it and i fully fund it but i want
you to get your house paid off and that
kind of stuff once you concentrate on
baby steps four five and six before we
start worrying about that too much
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
dead free stage jonathan and grace are
with us welcome guys how are you
great how are you doing great man where
do you all live uh we live in miramar
beach florida oh fun near dustin cool
welcome to nashville good to have you
guys thank you so all the way up here to
do a debt-free scream how much have you
paid off
uh we paid off uh 124
693 dollars cool how long did that take
26 months wow and your range of income
during that time uh somewhere around 140
to 160. cool what do you guys do for a
living
cpas
both of you both of us all right very
good fun so what kind of debt was this
125
000
well we had a cell phone to pay off for
about 600 bucks we had a credit card for
almost 14 000 a car loan for about 18
000 and then
92 000 was our mortgage oh you paid off
your house
cpas with a paid for house go baby i
love it
very cool good for you guys thank you
that's got to feel great feels awesome
obviously it's real but it's pretty good
pretty amazing how long you guys been
married
i let him answer that no 12 years almost
12 yeah 12 years
jonathan this is a test
[Laughter]
don't don't mess it up on the radio man
no that's funny all right 125 000 house
and everything in 26 months
couple of cpas been married 12 years but
something happened there
oh two and a half years ago what was the
wake up call got you plugged in on this
ramsey stuff and you guys went hog wild
yeah
well we've we've always kind of um
we've kind of been normal we've
used a credit card to pay you know pay
everything to get the points you know
like smart people
laugh laugh
and we you know we've we've always felt
like we've made decent money but we're
always kind of
wondering where it went and so we lacked
intentionality with our um
with our spending
and our budgeting and um
like 2018 i found out i just found out i
made partner in my firm and
um
things i thought things were going
really well and i got kind of caught up
in this
nfl
daily fantasy and winning some good
money and putting more and more into it
and then
you know hit the mother of all dry
spells about halfway through the season
and i was kind of putting a lot on the
credit card every every weekend to play
around this right after the super bowl i
remember seeing the credit card bills
going to be almost 14 000 that was one
month
and uh
we had just wiped out mostly grace
doesn't look happy right now no and she
recounts it she didn't chuckle no
it was not a laughing matter
and so i remember going to talk to her
about it and i had already been starting
to kind of trying to figure things out
i'd already started to listen to the
podcast
and i was like
listen this this next credit card bill
is going to wipe out all of our savings
she's like no no we just paid the 13 000
credit card bill i said no that was last
month's
this
so this one's going to wipe out all of
our savings but i think i think i have a
plan that we can we can get on and
really buckle down and
so it was kind of my mismanagement my
irresponsibility that pushed us over the
edge and
gave us our i had it moment
[Music]
watching watching uh my wife cry after
telling her that
was uh was really eye-opening and
it gave me the drive and the push to
submit to the to the plan
you know we bought the total money
makeover and read it to each other every
night
until we're done and then we were
gung-ho yeah
wow that's powerful
you guys are probably a little bit like
me maybe you're not i don't know but i
i've got a degree in finance
and they don't teach us
when you get a degree you can get a cpa
i mean a certified public accountant and
they'll teach you personal finance
you know we learn
you know debits and credits uh you know
we learn uh
gaap you know generally accept
accounting principles we learn
financial principles for corporate
america and for stock trades and all
these other things but uh the idea of
living on a lesson you make or the idea
that credit cards suck or the idea is
that
student loans don't have to be forever
they don't talk about that and we walk
out of there with a degree in business
right finance accounting and we don't
know beans about how to live that's true
and and yet i feel i kind of felt even
though i wasn't taught i still felt like
i should have known it yeah i got a
finance degree and i'm stupid i'm broke
i mean that's how i felt shame from that
a little bit i got two cpas here you
know and the wake up is freaking
football betting i mean my god you know
i mean it's the same thing it's just
this stuff's not taught anywhere and uh
we need to insert these uh ramsey
classes in the uh business curriculum at
these colleges i guess but way to go you
guys thank you way to go you took a
really messy nasty scary
angry frustrating situation and turned
it into wonderful your house has paid
off you've rocked
you are heroes man that's so cool
yeah i just wonder and i really
appreciate you jonathan sharing your
story i mean that's pretty vulnerable
stuff and there's a lot of emotion there
when you guys got you know full on into
this process and you walk it out now
you're debt free
um
that football betting that was kind of
pulling something there was something in
there that you it was it was engaging
now that you're on the other side you're
debt free and you walk through that pain
and fix that stuff
what are you excited about now what what
is your mind on when it comes to money
now
i think uh learning learning patience
and learning
that kind of tapped into my uh i've
always been trying to you know figure a
way to get rich quick a way to make a
quick profit a windfall profit
um and just uh
learning that uh you know the the the
tortoise always wins right yeah slow and
steady wins the race and uh and learning
to be patient i've still struggled with
that even through this process you know
just following the plan and not trying
to jump ahead and uh
so patience was was a big thing learning
for me i gotta ask grace too two cpas
when you actually started to get
together on this and got in the budget
meeting what's it like with two nerds in
there was it a true two nerd situation
um i'm kind of more of a balanced you
know i'm kind of free spirit and a nerd
okay so i'm kind of in the middle so
he's he's the nerd okay so i think a
first budget meeting i think i might
have cried i'm like we're doing what
we're spending only this much on this
so we definitely it took us a couple
months to kind of
you know get down to what the budget
should look like and what will work and
um
and you know what we need to spend i
mean grocery and eating out that was
like to our major spending you know
other than the fans football but
so kind of nailing down to you know what
we need to do to kind of make it work
and at the time i would just found out
we were pregnant with zoe my
two-year-old so it's kind of going
through pregnancy and hormones and
you know
cutting spending and that's when we you
want to spend you know you want to have
a new baby coming you want to buy new
things you're excited and yeah you know
so it was kind of it was a difficult
time kind of going through it but um
i mean patience and just trusting the
system and
um just
you know steady wins the race so we kind
of had and i had my moments where i'm
like okay i can't do this anymore we you
know and he would be like well just you
know
just let's stick to it and see you know
a few more months and we'll get there
and it seemed like the 26 months were
never gonna you know come it was just
kind of a long process but um
but we made it so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
you paid off your house and everything
in 26 months um let's see
i mean patience and just sit down and
budget i mean take off anything that
wants out of it and just keep the really
the needs that what you need to survive
on day to day
um you know that i mean we went through
um you know not buying the kids gifts uh
you know birthdays or not you know
all the gifts that we want to get him so
we'll get him like one thing instead of
10 things
just kind of the necessities and um i
think that helps and
just kind of working together and
trusting each other and
making sure that you know your spouse
your partner are on board and you know
if they start to fall out you know kind
of have doubts to kind of encourage them
and all right let's get the kids in
there what are their names and ages all
right we got joel who's six years old
and this is gabriella who's four and zoe
is two and we have baby madeline who's
gonna be three months tomorrow and west
is gonna be here
125 000 paid off in 26 months count it
down let's hear a debt free scream
three
two one
what a fun family that's awesomeness
right there very cool
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is our
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two two two five it is launch
day for paycheck to purpose his new book
the clear path to doing work you love
you can get it anywhere
great books are sold go buy it today you
can get it at uh you know any of the
great bookstores you can certainly get
it at ramseysolutions.com
uh amazon.com wherever you want to go
we'd love to it's 20 bucks here on sale
it's going to be a big week he's been
doing a bunch of major media and
going to be moving a whole bunch of
these this book is going to change some
people's lives without a doubt brittany
is with us in greensboro north carolina
hi brittany welcome to the ramsey show
hi
um can you hear me sure what's up yeah
my husband wants to go back to school
and we're working the baby steps and he
wants me to be open to loans student
loans
and i don't want to i do not want to do
that it absolutely terrifies me and i
don't know how to
still support him but stay on my ground
about not getting into it because we've
already been working the baby steps and
i want to keep
going forward in baby step two yeah
you're working the baby steps he's not
yeah yeah yeah
what's he want to study
he wants to go into school social work
you want to go into debt to do social
work yeah
do you know what that pays
i i know i know
i don't want to pay that much money
in student loans to go into debt i don't
even want to pay that much money to be a
social worker
they don't pay anything
what's he make now
he's at about 20 now he's a teacher
assistant
how old is he
he is 30.
assistant in a public school and he
wants to go into social work
yes
uh you know i think dave's right i think
i would expand the options certainly
social work is one path but there are
multiple paths
to probably do what he enjoys most about
social work for instance he probably has
a heart for the counseling side of it
the helping the advocating side does
that sound about right
that sounds right yeah
what college does he have any college
education so far
associates degree uh-huh
yeah i i gotta tell you uh finishing out
that the full degree because he's
already in the system and getting that
four-year degree finish would put him in
a position where he could potentially
move into some type of guidance
counselor role or something along those
lines but i think he's got to research
multiple options but getting that
student loan taking out loans to do a
degree to do social work it's just not
necessary because quite frankly he can
cash flow that i mean we teach that here
at ramsey solutions so if he buckles
down and is patient
right you guys have got to get through
the baby steps at certain points or he's
going to have to work harder and he's
going to have to cash flow his way
through maybe a second job but he
doesn't need the loan and it's it's
actually a bad business it's not a good
roi if that's what he really wants to do
taking out a loan for that is is really
a bad idea so brittany sometimes
when people
feel like they're stuck in a job
like he feels like he's stuck at this
public school in this resource role
right they they go oh what i need's a
degree
and that just pops into their head
because that's what we've been telling
people for a couple generations
and that's not necessarily a fact
what he needs is some clear direction on
what he wants to be
and what he wants to do exactly and then
determine if a degree is absolutely
necessary
is there a way that he can make 50 60 70
000 a year instead of 40
and not even have to get a degree to do
it uh yes there is
and maybe be in an area where he's
serving
the underprivileged in some way which is
what his heart is and that's a good
heart and i'm not against social workers
don't misunderstand me but i i the
number of people i've talked to that
spent 200 000 bucks on a master's degree
in social work to make 38 000 worth of
state makes me want to shoot somebody
that's just cray-cray
and i over the years of doing this i've
just seen a lot of people they destroy
their lives because they didn't lay out
their dream in such a way that it didn't
become a nightmare
and so i'm going to send you a copy of
ken's brand new book the from paycheck
to purpose
tell him to read that
and then the other book i'm going to
give you is our book here called debt
free degree
on how to go get a degree debt free and
time to read that and if he's not
willing to read two books he doesn't
need to go to school
right because at school they're going to
like require you to read books and stuff
yeah yeah yeah you catch the sarcasm
right
yes
i i've had several of the things you all
have said
all right you hold on kelly will pick up
and we'll ship those two
out to you but there's this mythical
thing it's not a genie in a bottle if
that's exactly what they they agree here
comes the genie hey
jesus you're three witches yes i grant
you your three wishes you now have a
degree you get to be whatever you want
to be before you weren't going to mount
anything but now you have got the genie
it's so that's a good that's a good line
well it's really robin williams voice on
the disney cartoon oh that's so good and
so that's the cultural pressure folks
make sure you catch that that's what
we've been told we've been marketed to
since the 50s that that's the only way
to success it's like the lie that you
have to buy a house 20 seconds after
you're an adult yeah or you're yes
you're wasting you're wasting your money
you're throwing your money down your
money out the window yeah and so you're
exactly right and that again one of the
major reasons why we wrote the book from
paycheck to purpose how do i figure out
what the mountaintop is that's where
this gentleman's at it might be social
work
but how do you go from it might be i
think it is to i know it is and that's
the stage one that we'd start with get
clear get clear does it align with how
i'm created does social work involve
skills that i actually have or some raw
talent that i can hone into skills do i
love the work that if you read a
description under social work
would that make your heart come alive if
you spent 75 percent of your day doing
that then the final pieces mission
does it produce results does social work
or that type of work produce results
that fill your heart up with hey hey
this is significant to me that's the
ultimate test there and if the answer is
yes go for it lindsay's in san diego hi
lindsay welcome to the ramsay show
thank you hi dave hi ken congrats on
that book launch thank you excited to
get my copy thank you very much
yeah so a quick question my 13 year old
son started working for a family friend
a couple hours a week and earns about 40
to 60 a week he wants to invest the
majority of that money after tithing
obviously do you have a suggestion as to
where he should park this money
well here's the thing
the goal of this investment is not
wealth
because it's not much money number one
and
number two it's not much money so it's
not going to turn into much money
okay so the goal is to create knowledge
and to reward his interest
in the subject
and to
teach him what to do when he's an adult
and so i don't want to have him doing
stuff that i wouldn't tell him to do if
he's an adult because we're endorsing it
by telling him to do it now
i mean he could sometimes teenagers get
in a little stock club or something and
they'll buy and sell single stocks but i
don't tell adults to do that i don't do
it so i don't really want to train a
teenager that that's the proper way to
do this the problem that this presents
is if i'm going to train him to invest
in good mutual funds
you can get with a smartvestor pro and
open up a mutual fund for fifty dollars
a month
and you be the custodian he can't open
an account until he's 21 but he you can
open it as in his name with you as the
custodian
and uh he can have it automatically
drafted get him a checking account all
of that
all of that would be good learning
exercise
and he can learn to calculate the value
of his shares and see what they do
here's the thing
over the period of 12 months which when
you're 13 years old is an eternity
there's not going to be a lot of action
it's kind of boring
okay and that's the downside of this but
that's what i did with our kids
we uh we opened up mutual funds they
could add to them and we would show them
how to calculate the shares and one of
the things we taught them was that it's
a little boring this wealth building
thing it's slow and steady wins the race
it's not sexy it's not jumping all over
the place it's not get rich quick it's
not something you get to brag to your
friends
it's just kind of there
and i don't want to train him to do
anything else because that's what i want
him to do
so that's what i did
thank you lindsey this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world subscribe or follow today
wherever you listen to podcast
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us america it's a free
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five ken coleman
is my co-host today ramsey personality
here on the air we're answering your
questions about career about money about
life triple eight eight two five five
two two five now
launch day for his new book it is now
available in stores
soon to be another national bestseller
from paycheck to purpose the clear path
to doing work you love ken's second book
his first was the number one bestseller
and this one i suspect will be as well
or very close if not we're right there
at it it's going to happen and it's good
it's good and those of you helping out
there by buying the book we appreciate
it that's helpful um and the book is
gonna change your life it's got the
seven clear stages to find and to engage
in
work you love
and uh you spend the vast majority of
your waking hours at work so don't do it
doing something you hate yeah 55 of
americans right now are actively
considering moving on and of that group
two-thirds of them don't know what
they're looking for and so there's a
tremendous amount of frustration right
now uh with folks and it starts with let
me get clear about what my options are
what are the pathways and then how do i
go about doing it you know so let's
overcome these myths that you got to get
a college degree or a master's degree or
higher degree just to be able to move
forward can you do it while in the baby
steps the answer is yes too
these seven stages work in lockstep with
the baby steps they don't take you a
different direction and there are times
where you have to pause of the the seven
stages to doing work you love that
purpose will work but you can get there
the dream is still gonna be there so
we're really excited about the book and
it's gonna help a lot of people and uh
for those days who are looking for a
quicker kind of all right i wanna i
wanna turn the book into a field guide
up the mountain we've also got that get
clear career assessment at
ramseysolutions.com that goes with the
book helps you dive deep in about a
20-minute assessment get really really
clear and start to move forward great
tool that thing is uh man almost 10 000
people have already taken this it's
pretty incredible
so from paycheck to purpose the clear
path to doing work you love anywhere
great books are sold including
ramseysolutions.com amazon the fine
french store target
and of course barnes and noble anywhere
great books are you can find this book
frankie's with us in phoenix arizona
starting off this hour hi frankie
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave and ken
thanks for taking my call
um
i'm in a quandary
i am 75 years old i have no children
i have a house that i live in and i have
two rental properties one is completely
paid off and the other i owe 6 000 on
um so i'm able to supplement my social
security
and between the two houses
uh if i have it at market rent which one
is at market right now the other one
is not yet because i'm in the process of
rehabbing it while my tenant is still in
there so that's been a long process
he wants to buy it and that's why he
wanted to stay in it
so
when that other house is up to
uh when it's completed the renovations
completed i will have about 30 000 in it
because the house was built in 1955 so
it needed a whole lot of updates and
renovation
and so i'll be netting a total of a
little over 20 000 a year from the two
rentals
that are paid where we will be paid off
um but the tenant wants to buy it
market value right now
is i paid 70 000 for 13 years ago i have
the same tenant for 13 years because
i've kept his rent below market
so now i've offered it to him twice
before to buy it he said no
now he wants to buy it because he knows
i'm going to up the rent
and so
you are one sharp cookie
so
i'm trying to decide
sell it or keep it
yeah okay
let's just stop i don't want to be mean
to him or anything but what he wants is
not relative to me
all that matters to me is what you want
so you're 75 when you're 80.
do you want to own
these two rental properties it sounds to
me like you're pretty good at it and you
may want to own them
well i have
been different states and the one that's
cash flowing very well
um i have a wonderful property manager
he's great
and so i trust him completely
and he's doing a really good job for me
uh this other one that's not quite paid
off and has a tenant in it i've been
managing it from a distance because i've
had this same guy in it
it's in dallas okay and you're in
phoenix all right sounds to me it sounds
to me like you might have an itch to
sell it
well and its market value right now is
between 180 and 190 and i paid 70 for it
right so you're gonna have some capital
gains
a lot
yeah but not 250 so i i don't have to
worry well of course it's a rental so i
don't have any write-off exactly on that
so yeah whatever you're and you probably
have adjusted you're probably written
off depreciate your basis down to
nothing so it's probably all yes it's
probably all gain yeah yeah and um so
it's going to be uh it's going to be a
30 000 tax bill
yes i'm aware of that right
the question i'm asking is this
regardless of what your tenant wants
what does frankie want
well you know
before he wanted to buy it i'm thinking
well i've built myself a pretty good
annuity i mean
i'm not have to pay any you know when
you buy annuities i think that's not
reasonable for me and so i feel like i
built myself this annuity
by having these two properties now
when i'm 85 yeah but when i'm 85 do i
want to mess with it i don't know
i don't think so okay
all right i mean it's up to you it's a
good time to sell if you want to sell
but you don't need to sell by the cause
the market's telling you to sell and you
don't need to sell because the tenant
wants you to sell you need to sell
because you
want to sell and here's the thing after
talking to you for just a few minutes
you're sharp
you already know down inside what what
feels right to you
and you can trust your instincts frankie
after talking to you you got good
instincts that's right that's why she
said quandary she's going i know what i
want to do but i'm feeling pressure
somewhere else and i think she's feeling
pressure because she's a nice lady i
think she's gonna keep it five more
years and then she's gonna sell it i
think so too that's what i think she's
gonna do but i i think this tenant is
one she wants to keep this guy happy and
you know what he's been happy long
enough he's been there 13 years at
reduced rent it's time for him to not be
happy yeah tough man go go you're a big
boy go buy yourself a house somewhere
else it's your house that's not greedy
it's just doing business i love it i
mean i we we raise rents on ours every
single time they come due even if it's
20 bucks
because i don't want anybody thinking
that it's going to be locked in that way
for 10 years no dave it's because you're
an evil slum lord just admit it you evil
heartless really nice slums but yeah
it's a really nice but yeah there you go
but i am heartless and greedy
there's no question yes no doubt about
it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today we're coming into the time
of year where money stress can pile up
yep christmas is coming at us the list
of christmas gifts is uh
starting to build
and extra travel expenses oh and extra
food yeah all of this all of it's got to
get done and what if the money was
something you never had to worry about
what if you're never worried about
christmas
well it's actually possible you just
need a plan
and that's what you get when you become
a ramsey plus member we'll put you into
financial peace university our class
that's taught
just under 10 million people
where you'll learn the plan that's
helped millions save for emergencies
pay off debt fast and build wealth
and then you'll put that plan into
action by budgeting with the premium
version of every dollar
when you're not always worried about
money you get to live the life you
really want so christmas give yourself a
gift that will actually help you get
there faster let's do a free trial to
ramsey plus which will get you into
financial peace university and into
every dollar a free trial text trial to
33 789 that's trial to 33789
blinds.com gives us our question of the
day find out for yourself why blinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window coverings with free
samples free shipping and new promos
every month you're gonna save even more
always use the promo code
ramseyblinds.com a great american
company
all right talk about it ken all right
sean is uh giving us the question today
he's in wisconsin i'm currently working
for an hvac building automation controls
company at a local branch as a project
manager i'm a mechanical engineer and
have been working in the automation
field since college over the last four
and a half years i've grown to hate the
industry and i feel like i i've made a
major mistake taking on the project
manager's role i'm learning that
managing other projects and people is
not a strength of mine and i find that
it is nearly impossible not to take work
home with me i'm more of a people
pleaser and tend to not delegate work
well what are some good ways to qualify
for work that would ultimately need more
education to be qualified
in parentheses he puts programming
technical support while not going into
debt okay so the way it's worded it's a
little fuzzy here but if you're looking
to get into uh programming
tech support work sean i can tell you
right now uh you don't have to get a
college degree there are so many
certification programs
and training programs that you can get
that qualified
skill set and some experience to be able
to get into that but you're going to
need to be patient and hang on i know
you're in a situation right now where
you're being drained
but we want to hang tight unless in that
project management role if you can
replace that income right now in a
temporary move hourly work doing
something else it just gets you out of
that management role where he's kind of
sucking the soul out of you
but you're going to keep your same
income or maybe make a little bit more
an hourly temporary role do that while
you're getting qualified but dave bethel
tech's a great example they uh they
sponsor uh ken coleman they're part of
the ramsey network and this is a great
program nine month program
less than fifteen thousand dollars they
allow you to cash flow your way through
it because they support and believe in
what we do and uh their people are
starting out making sixty five to seven
thousand coding schools coding
programming technical uh just you don't
have to have any prior experience or
uh revealed skill set they can train you
for technical jobs when we look at
programming any type of technology work
that's just one example do your homework
kick the tires a lot of great programs
that are affordable and not that time
consuming to get qualified so i'm
wondering mechanical engineer that's
what his background is yeah
if there isn't a different application
for that that wasn't merely project
managing automation stuff yeah and
mechanical engineers can
he may be spatially minded he may be
able to see things in 3d
and you know
there may be a whole lot of different
applications for his existing tons of
versatility his existing uh degree
that would be different than what he's
doing i i i mean he's got he's stepped
into a very narrow nuance of what he
could be doing i agree and that's like
we love those phone calls because when
we dive into this we go okay so
you're in the two things that you said
you don't like are the project managing
which is logistics in nature
and then the
people stuff which is leadership he
might just be a guy likes to fix things
with his head and hands that mechanical
part of the engineering and he's in this
project management which it's got a lot
of people
even if he's not fixing with his hands
even if he's drawing uh mechanical
engineering that's correct
lots of options and solving you know
creating solutions
by his uh correct methodology by by
creating the item the mechanical
engineering solution yeah um i know we
do a ton with mechanical engineers
around here we're wiring these studios
putting stuff together we're building
this conference center up on the hill
we've got a outsourced mechanical
engineering with the with architectural
firms sure because it's so much detail
there and we had to solve a lot of
problems there and i don't know but what
that
you know you don't have to be in a uh
you know a project management situation
with no not at all it feels like he this
is one of those situations we hear a lot
i fell into this well or i heard that
you know people are making a lot of
money coding maybe i need to be a coder
so he jumps over to do that i don't know
maybe he needs to be a coder that's okay
yeah if he does i need i need some
coders so that's great i mean we need
some programmers here so yeah that's a
good point we do you know but the uh uh
you know pretty cool pretty cool good
stuff
the book is paycheck to purpose it
launched today the clear path to doing
work you love by ken coleman leanne is
with us in san antonio hi leanne how are
you
i'm well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so first let me just say i pre-ordered
ken's book and this call is really
probably more for you
well thank you
thank you what's going on
so um
we're in baby step two my husband and i
and he
recently in june had to take a job that
cut his pay in half
i have been a stay-at-home mom for over
why because he worked in
um
a trans he's an electrician he works on
building tunnels in cities
transportation and all those jobs have
drive had dried up and so he took a job
with a company who does the same thing
but it's a private company not unionized
he's excited for that job because he's
getting older and is using all the
knowledge that he's gained in all those
years but it cut our pay in half so i've
been a stay-at-home mom for 25 plus
years and i haven't been in the
workforce but our kids are grown and i
want to
contribute people financially
to make up the pay cut that he took
but i've been out of work for 25 years
and i don't even know what to do i mean
i homeschooled my kids sure i did take
how much little job don't go ahead how
much money do we need to make for you if
you're making up that 50 what's the
number
well it
it would be in at any i think 50 would
be less than what made up i mean he made
250 last year he's making 92 000 this
year okay so you so you're trying to
make 50 to 100 is what would be making
it up but right now you've been out of
the workforce for 25 years so here's
what we start with we start with the
clues of talent what do you do very very
well and you didn't lose that skill set
you might be rusty but we want to start
with talent what do you really really do
well and that's going to get you some
clues but i'm just curious what would
you do tomorrow if you knew the money
was there and you knew you couldn't fail
because for 25 years being a homemaker
your mind is wondered at some point what
would that be give me just one answer
that you don't have to lock into
um
i really enjoy and i've done it i
working in ministry with young people
like i worked as a youth director at my
youth camp or at our church um what i
really loved for a little bit i was the
executive director of the crisis
pregnancy center and i served on that
board for 11 years and i really love
that word all right so we'll start there
as one really good option you've got a
lot of experience and a lot of skill
being an executive director running a
non-profit you've also worked in
ministry so you know those lanes you
know how to lead people you know how to
lead projects i would be looking in
those areas right now this is not going
to make up though that gap that your
husband took so i want to address that
very very quickly but i'll get to that
in a second but leon i want you to be
looking for opportunities local
ministries
uh crisis practice centers nonprofits
get in there if you've got a volunteer
to start to get in there but i want to
challenge your husband
as an electrician a skilled electrician
i know he likes what he's doing but he
could be making way more i would
challenge him
unless you guys can absorb that pay cut
i'd be looking for a better electrician
opportunity
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work first go
to
ziprecruiter.com ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five
zack and bronwyn are with us in savannah
georgia says on my screen you guys are
debt-free congratulations
thank you dave hi ken hi
very cool how much have you paid off
yeah so we uh we started 86 a little
over 86 000.
good deal how long did that take
just well it it took about 10 months to
get the 86 um paid off but we started
probably three years ago okay 10 months
for 86 000 and during that 10 months
what was your range of income
our income was 160
right now about 190. good what do you
guys do for a living
um i work for a construction equipment
manufacturer here in savannah and i'm
i'm at the port
okay very cool good for you guys
savannah's a great town
very fun
so uh 86 000 of what kind of debt
it's all consumer um and then 27
27 000 student loans so we had 22 in
credit cards and 37 in cars and then
the remainder student loans
nice cars
yeah yeah we got three kids so
big cars okay all right fun
so how long you guys been married
oh five years yeah we both had to think
about it yeah so uh
what happened 10 months ago put you on
this ramsey stuff
well ten months ago really i i heard
about you in 2018 i was actually
pregnant with our second child and i was
over
seas i actually was on a seven hour
flight that pregnant and um
listen to your audiobook book the total
money makeover and i mean the whole
flight i'm like oh my gosh i gotta get
off this flight because i've got to
figure out how to pay off all this debt
i was running all the numbers in my head
so we dave-ished it honestly
for
a couple years clearly we were
preoccupied with new baby and then 10
months ago we realized
after looking at our budget that we just
made too much money to be
you know
living paycheck to paycheck and and when
i looked at the numbers we had paid
year-to-date just on credit cards about
35 000 and i was like but they're not
even paid off so all in all like we'll
pay
57 000
in credit cards and what do we have to
show for it so
it just like
it flipped us on our end and we we were
like we can't do it our way we've gotta
go back to basics so we signed up for
financial piece um online and did the
ramsey solutions
um
and started budgeting and that made all
the difference wow i got to ask bronwyn
so you get off this plane i could just
see you going excuse me pardon me excuse
me pardon me you wanted to get back home
and get after it zach she comes home all
fired up did you jump right in and say
all right okay uh sure
yeah yeah that was how the first
conversation you know while she was over
there we had and then she had the audio
so i was i was listening to it while she
was sleeping feeding the baby listening
to it
and really well i'd say got all in but
it was about you know 10 months ago
where where enough was enough and i was
fully in fully on board
so you guys that's when you signed up
for financial peace university and
that's when you got on the every dollar
app and everything
that's right yeah
yeah
yeah that's right we um
you know we kind of like did it our way
dave we we kept our savings account up
because we were nervous because we had
kids and we had you know a lot of
overhead to make up and every month and
we didn't want to be in a bad place but
we're just very cautious and then you
know
really i'm the spender and he's the you
know he put me on a budget day one we
met i think so
[Laughter]
i love it well congratulations you guys
very very very well done how does it
feel now that you're free
um it feels free and and
free 10 months ago was a different
meaning
um
you know if someone asked me now
what it is to be free i mean it's it's
it's it's like taking off a bag of
bricks and you didn't even know you were
carrying them yeah really that's for
sure
so um what do you tell people the key
now you've been through financial peace
and then you actually did it you paid
off the 86 000. what's the key to
getting out of debt what are the things
they need to do if they're listening
right now
so uh my advice would take take your
wife or husband's amazon card hide it
throw it away cut it up
get that thing out of there
guilty sounds very specific zach
yeah
guilty disconnect amazon prime
yeah but definitely keep the momentum um
once you once you
pay off one thing
keep it going um you kind of start
seeing that the snowball you know to be
cliche the snowball really does just
keep rolling and it gets exciting the
more you pay off the more excited you
get the more fired ups you get so just
just keep keep going keep the motivation
there
very cool good stuff you guys we're
proud of you way to go heroes those
little babies lives are changed because
mom and daddy decided to take control of
this money stuff
very very cool we got a copy of the
legacy journey for you uh that's the
next chapter in your story to be
baby steps millionaires before you know
it and i will also send you an extra
copy of the total money makeover you can
give that away and maybe they'll come
off a plane somewhere and uh come home
and go we're doing this that might work
you never know or they may use it as the
world's largest and best coaster it has
been used for that on coffee tables all
over america but it rises again but it
always comes back it has a second life
yeah it always comes back
when people need it the book is just
suddenly laying there it's kind of
amazing all right zach and bronwyn way
to go savannah georgia 86 000 paid off
in 10 months making
160 to 190 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
all right three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
that is how it's done
very cool you guys very cool very well
done david is in salt lake city utah hi
david how are you
doing great dave ken it's great to talk
to you and i really appreciate all that
you do sure what's up
well my wife and i have hit some
benchmarks in life and right now we are
energetically debating whether we should
sell one of our rental houses or just
buckle down and try and weather out the
next two to three years
so
we bought our first house about 24 years
ago when we lived in idaho and shortly
after that i was transferred down to
salt lake for work but we kept the house
thinking we would always move back to
that and we've just been renting it ever
since
and uh
we the the two big things going on in
our lives right now is one is my wife
has just started the first
first semester of a
two and a half year advanced degree
program so she's going to become a nurse
practitioner good
and the second
is that our renter in this idaho house
has stopped paying the rent so we're now
in the process of evicting him and the
house will soon be empty good
yeah yeah so with it being empty
you know we started talking again should
we
clean it up get it re-rented quickly or
is this the right time how much what's
it worth
um
just a quick look at the real estate
market we think it would probably sell
for about three hundred thousand what's
old on it
uh zero we paid it off okay a long time
ago so you have three hundred thousand
dollars in a pile on your kitchen table
uncle benjamin franklin is looking at
you with the eye
do you take that money and do something
with it or do you go buy a rental house
in idaho
not idaho for sure
sell it
yeah it's about two and a half hours
away and sell it when we go up and visit
family we're we're working there sell it
sell it
there's nothing fun in this equation i
love real estate but you everything
you've described to me is this is all
the words had fatigue in them yeah i
heard tired i'm tired i'm sick and tired
that's what i heard i heard that in your
voice i don't know if it's i don't know
who's debating which way on this but
it's a 26 year old dream you're ever
going to live in that house you're not
going to live in that house again
if you go back to idaho you wouldn't
move in that house
salad
that's what i would do
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personalities my
co-host today we're launching his brand
new book today it's launch day here at
ramsey the book is from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing
work you love ellen is with us in san
antonio hi ellen how are you
i'm doing well today how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
well it's um it's an honor to be
speaking with both you and ken today i
actually called in a few weeks ago
asking for advice about staying in my
current workplace based on a
relationship i had or
moving on and
that's why i'm calling i took your
advice i decided to pursue other
opportunities
that were offered to me at that point
however
one of the organizations my top choice
they didn't get back to me immediately
after the interview so i followed up
with them
following some of kim's advice about
adding value based on what we had talked
about in the in the interview a couple
days later they get back to me
and they um
they offer
or they invite me to apply for a program
management position
instead of the case management position
that i had initially applied for
so my question for you guys today is
while
obviously something in the interview
told them that i might be a good fit for
this program management position on
paper when i look at it
i don't see how my my experience and my
qualifications match up so i just i want
to know how to show up with humility but
also confidence
for this job interview when i don't
quite believe that i am technically
qualified for it okay that's a really
good question okay so can you be
specific what parts of the job
description when you look at it you go i
don't know if i can pull that off what
can you tell me
so
there are just some very technical
qualifications about um it's a refugee
resettlement organization so
having to do with some policy and some
uh
experiencing managing like the
applications for
for getting people over here basically
there's that kind of knowledge and then
i don't have
technically this type of management or
supervisory experience i want to be a
program manager someday great but i
thought that was more of a five to ten
year plan not necessarily a right now
thing okay great
but they saw something in you i'm going
to repeat what you said to dave and i
they saw something and they they're
suggesting you come interview for it
they didn't offer it to you and you
don't have to dance you know you can you
can come in and listen and you get to
decide remember a job interview ellen is
just as much for you as it is for the
potential employer
so you're not committing you're not a
fraud you're not wasting their time go
in there and have a conversation as it
relates to leading people no one's ever
really ready to lead once you lead for
the first time you're going to learn the
process of leadership and and it's it is
a learnable skill and if you just serve
people if you ask the question these two
questions on a regular basis as a first
time leader how are you doing this is
the team that you will lead how are you
doing that's a personal question check
on these folks how are they doing it's
not a greeting in the hallway second
question is how can i help you win in
your role if you were to just ask those
two questions at the very beginning on a
consistent basis you're going to learn
the heart of leadership which is servant
leadership i'm not concerned about that
piece
i think you've got to ask yourself
i don't have the knowledge but if they
teach me how to handle the technical
portion of that refugee peace and all
that stuff
i think you could learn that just
because you don't know it doesn't mean
you can't learn it do you agree
i do agree then go to the interview and
have confidence that you're a teachable
person are you teachable
uh yes i would say i'm very teachable
good okay and you're so you're
self-aware you're not strutting in there
acting like you're too cool for school
and you're not you know so you know
what's going on you go listen i've never
done those two things to but i think you
can show me how and i think i can do
them
all right and i i'm guessing i don't
need to no i don't want to mislead you
and act like i've got five years of
experience but if you'll show me how to
do these two things i think i can learn
how to do them and i think i can do this
and ellen asked this question at some
point in the interview when you have a
chance to talk ask would you describe
what a win looks like
now this is not a job description but
what does winning look like in this role
and have them describe that to you if
there's holes in that and you don't
understand ask follow-up questions and
when you get a sense for that um then
you're gonna have a really good idea
whether or not you a can do it and b
want to do it but go in there and just
have a good conversation with them you
don't have to commit
all right um
that's basically you know what you don't
know what's weird
you don't want to you want to know
what's weird ken and i and the people at
that company think you're more qualified
than you think you are absolutely right
you've got self-doubt on you like a big
heavy coat no she's just trying to be
honest she's a person of integrity and
she looks at things through details and
she knows she can't check those boxes
yeah but the fact that we believe in her
more than they're but i think those
boxes are checkable that's the point
absolutely somebody who knows how to get
up leave the kids kill something and
drag it home kid oh you can do this yes
tim is with us tim is in pittsburgh hi
tim how are you
i'm doing
better than we deserve what's up
awesome i am a senior in college i'm
studying finance and i recently accepted
my first big boy job clay
what are you gonna be doing i'm gonna be
i'm to be doing finance for a food
company cool and what are they paying
you
they're paying me 67. i love it good for
you nice job
thank you so this involves a move
halfway across the country
um i have essentially nothing to my name
but no debt luckily i was blessed with
that
and i'm just wondering where to start
because i'm excited to work for the
company but at the same time i'm also
terrified of making that move
what terrifies you
well i don't really have like i said i
don't have anything physically so i'm
going to need to buy a car you need to
buy furniture going to need to get an
apartment
all that stuff so if anyone set myself
up
i'm sorry you have any money
i do i have a few thousand that i'd be
able to put but um
that would allow me to stay with a 1 000
emergency fund but
it wouldn't be
oh sorry go ahead are you moving to a
metro a kind of a metro area where you
don't have to have a car for a season
until you get employed and start putting
a budget together
the problem with the company is that
there it isn't a metro but there aren't
any transit lines that really go to it
and there aren't many apartments in that
area
okay
[Music]
so you have
you said a few thousand how much how
much money do you actually have give me
the exact number
oh gosh um
probably liquid cash i would say
five to six okay uh retirement probably
six or seven and then
miscellaneous brokerage is probably
about five
miscellaneous brokerage of five thousand
yeah okay so you have eleven thousand
dollars
not counting retirement
yeah dude go buy a two thousand dollar
car get you an apartment and get some
cheap used furniture yeah
get going
you got it man it ain't nothing okay
listen go the rich into town when you
get there to garage sales and you can
buy a six thousand dollar leather couch
for 400 bucks yeah yeah
and you don't have to have a tv for two
weeks
and you don't have to have cable for the
first week and you don't have to have
that to that to that right
okay
and um
so just you know you you got
you just put off some of the stuff but
you go in there get a basic apartment
and you know just get you
a mattress and throw it on the floor and
then you start getting paychecks you're
going to get 5 000 bucks a month
paychecks
and you can start buying stuff then okay
and cash flowing but you know all you
got to have is some one little place to
sleep get you an apartment get you a
little beater car and that'll get you
started and then this time next year buy
you a good car with cash
okay you're used to living on nothing
you're getting ready to make 67 000 how
much of that can you save between the
the next year and this time in one year
cool yeah probably a lot more than yeah
yeah so because you're used to living on
nothing it's easy right so just say i'm
gonna i'm gonna save up for a 15 000 car
good and probably do that by like
freaking christmas you know not quite
but i mean when do you go when do you
move
late june good for you okay so you've
even got more time to pile up money
yeah and you're not looking for a sexy
car here you're looking for a reliable
car
it might even be a little beat up but
it's great mechanically all you want to
do is get back and forth to work till
you make enough paychecks to go get you
a good car
that's all you're doing just pay cash
for everything move slow don't try to
impress anybody nothing you buy in this
first four months is going to impress a
girl except the right kind of girl this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us america it's a free
call at triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five
two two five my co-host today on the
ramsey show ramsey personality number
one best-selling author ken coleman it
is book launch day here at ramsey he has
a new book that is officially on sale
today you order it we'll ship it today
if you pre-ordered it they all went out
this morning or last night or whatever
so that you'll be getting them in your
mailbox very very soon amazon also
released and of course so did all the
major book outlets like barnes and noble
and target and so on uh you'll see this
book everywhere from paycheck
to purpose
the clear path
to doing work you love from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing work you
love you'll be seeing ken on media all
over the place he's been doing media
since 5am this morning and we're also
here answering your questions about your
career your job and of course money in
life it's what we're here for triple
eight eight two five five
two two five getting towards the end of
the first day of the book launch are you
tired i am i'm glad you mentioned that
i've been up since 4 15 because if i
begin to babble we'll blame it on that
that's probably not what the problem is
but we'll blame it on just getting up
early see i don't even have an excuse
if i babble james just says stop
babbling right
it happens when you do live radio as
much as you've done it or any of us get
to do there's those moments where the
brain
sometimes just betrays you
well i gotta tell you man james has been
torturing me all morning what yeah i've
been in the studio down there recording
a audio that's oh you're extra tired too
audiobook for four freaking years your
brain feels like liquid
man i'm just it's i know that i can't
it's brutal i'm not good at it oh really
no i'm awful huh
and like i say words backwards and oh
okay god it's he stops me and i start
over and it's just
i tried to hire morgan freeman but
[Laughter]
sounds a lot like dave james earl jones
was not available so we got dave yeah
i would love to be a fly on the wall
after about the 17th interruption from
james for dave to do a lineup now
because the problem is he doesn't
interrupt me unless he's right and oh
it's not something i can really argue
about i know it's true isn't it
every time you really just have to take
the weapon it's the truth there's just
no way around it that's part of it
adam's with us in boise idaho hey adam
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
uh so i have a question um
my wife and i have a couple of different
options for our health insurance for
coming up next year
and i'm wondering if it's smarter for us
to
each get our own plans
and have the children on her plan
and we would have a cheaper option that
way and then we would both get employer
hsa contributions
or if the smarter option or your
preferred res recommended option would
be to
put a family on one plan
if it costs more
but and you don't get as many um
employer hsa contributions for the year
but we would have how much more
deductible
uh
the plan cost to put me on her plan to
be like another
865 dollars a year
and then we'd miss out on a thousand
dollars of hsa contributions from my
employer i'm not worried about that
how much deductible exposure
is there on each of these
so
her deductibles are 3 000 individual and
6 000 family
my plan would be
1750
individual and 3 500 for family but you
don't have family on your plan
i have an option but it's i know but
under your proposal
it would be her and the kids on hers and
you on yours but you're picking up an
extra
little bit of deductible in return
you're losing eight hundred grand
or eight hundred dollars i'm sorry not a
hundred grand
not hardly
uh
i mean for the hassle factor i'd be
tempted to put it all on one plan just
because messing with everything and the
fact if if you get into a deductible
situation your max out of pocket um is
going to end up free but i'm guessing
you guys are a young family and you're
pretty healthy so you're probably not
blowing through these deductibles are
you
correct yeah and this is the first year
since that we were on like this hsa
options we were on completely different
insurance yeah but i'm gonna talk about
that i'm just talking about i'm talking
about your use of health insurance
you guys don't go
blow a bunch of money on medical at this
stage of your life correct yeah
okay i'm going the cheaper route then
with you separate from your wife and
kids
okay and you get you get both get the
hsa so you understand you've done the
analysis you said it out loud i'm making
sure you understood the analysis you did
was what you're accepting is you're
saving 800 but you're taking extra risk
on the deductible
i'm betting that that's a good move
because you're probably not going to
blow through the deductible
right that was kind of my thought
process as well okay that was that's
what i thought i heard you saying and
that's what i that's what i heard too
so um yeah i'm with you on that i think
we're gonna go the cheaper route now are
both of these reasonably good care the
networks are got your docks in them that
kind of stuff or you feel like you're
cheaping out on one of them
no they're both probably equally as good
okay
all right yeah that's what i would do
then good question there's a lot of
stuff going on it is the season right
now you have open season right yeah on
ducks yeah on geese and on
pheasant and on healthcare yes that's
true
we did something very similar to that
before we had three kids and we just had
the one and stacy with and so that that
really is a good move because why we
have the emergency fund and so we took
that cheaper option and the risk isn't
really that risky because that's why we
have an emergency fund then as we
started getting multiple kids
ear infections ear drums all that then
we had to adjust because we had several
years there we had higher expenses yeah
the thing is that the
the hsa if you are healthy or if you're
chronically ill
where you're always blown through the
deductible and if your hsa has uh you
know 100 pay
after you blow the deductible which most
of them do not all of them but a lot of
them do ours does not we have a copay
after you blow the deductible but a lot
of them are 100 after that uh if you're
chronically ill and you're gonna blow
that deductible that comes out cheaper
yes it does and if you're not gonna
touch the deductible which the ramses
have been knock on wood pretty healthy
bunch over the years we've not really
used our health insurance hardly at all
very seldom in a year have we actually
tapped into that and hit the deductible
so
um
given that what you end up with net net
with a hsa a high deductible health
insurance plan
with hsa attached to it what you end up
with is basically cheaper health
insurance that's correct because you're
basically running a high deductible any
insurance you can run a higher
deductible on and you have the emergency
fund to cover it is going to create a
lower premium duh
the question is is it work are you
getting a low enough premium to offset
the extra risk you're taking on the
deductible that's true on your car
insurance your homeowner's insurance
it's true on
anything where there's a deductible
involved but health insurance as well
and so that's the way you guys really
need to pay attention right now during
open season for most of you as to what
you're doing
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
you
still on baby step number one
how did you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five we've all heard the
saying it's better to give
than to receive and you know what it's
more fun too
and while you can have a great time
giving the latest gadgets or gizmos to
the folks on your christmas list you may
also want to give them something that
has an impact
something that might change their lives
that's why every year we bring back our
famous 10 sale it gives you the chance
to shop over 40 of our best-selling
books and envelopes for envelope systems
for only ten dollars or less you'll find
books like our number one bestseller the
total money makeover and for the first
time ever rachel cruz's newest book know
yourself know your money is on sale for
just 10 bucks this year you can gift a
lifetime of hope just check out the 10
sale at ramseysolutions.com
and don't forget here at ramsey we like
to give gifts too we have such a blast
giving stuff away that we've already
started giving away cash for christmas
every year we celebrate christmas with
the ramsey show listeners with an
awesome tradition the ramsey christmas
cash giveaway this year we're giving
away 500
every week and a grand prize of five
thousand bucks you can enter every day
to increase your chances of winning text
cash to 33
789 you want to register for the 500
bucks a week five thousand dollar grand
prize text cash to three three
seven eight nine jody is in dayton ohio
hi jody how are you
uh better than i deserve dave um thanks
for taking my call sure what's up
i have a little bit of a question going
through a disillusion or divorce
basically and it's kind of left me in a
financial ruin i feel like um
i was with the guy for 16 years and
cheated on me and it's been really
devastating and i had like a really good
financial goal to be debt-free in like
seven years you know
start my family
it's just not worked out that way and so
what i'm looking at is i make 73 a year
i have a 401k of 55 000.
i've got quite a bit of cash on hand
liquid cash would be about 46 000 which
i was probably either going to pay off
my student debt which is
38 000
or you know pay off part of it and maybe
invest and hope that in a few years that
investment grows and i can just really
tackle down for debt with that
my
house right now the appraisal on it was
625 000.
and i owe 189 on it
but with the payout to my husband after
this disillusion i'll be paying him out
about 95 000.
i'm kind of left with
i think uh let's see here
a 322 000 loan now on the house by
myself making 73 000 a year my payment
um if i consolidate like my college into
my house
and kind of just sit on that because
it's been so much of a change i feel
like i might have to go to a mental
hospital basically like it's just like
so much i we actually built this house
last year we finished business
[Music]
with the dream house you know to raise
the family in with him
but i just you know my payments looking
at like 1900 to possibly 20
22 or 2100 at the max is what the bank
is telling me
how old are you
what'd you say how old are you
i'm going to be 32 on december 1st um
okay
i'm so sorry
yeah thanks i'm too
you're not gonna like me but i'm gonna
love you well okay
yeah
sell the house
okay
you know why
well i'd not have the stress of the
financial debt i'm sure yeah you get to
start fresh with a clean white board
you don't walk in there every day
looking at a custom-made home that was a
dream home that you built with a guy who
committed adultery on you
yeah
your heart's broken and every time you
walk in the living room it's gonna break
again
and you're paying a huge payment for the
privilege
and i mean the best way to start fresh
after a broken heart is start fresh
okay
and it's just i'm just cleaning i just
want to clean i just want your life to
be clean and simple to give you a place
where you can heal from this because
this has been really hard for you
and what what kind of time frame should
i be looking at to make this transition
because it's like
right now
um
i i just don't know like with so many
changes i had to get the vaccine so i
didn't lose my job you know
um
so i did that but it's just like i just
i feel like if i have like one more
major change yeah yeah
what i would do is just try to get life
as simple as i can
until you start breathing again
right now you're not taking deep breaths
you're just kind of
you got the stress on it's like somebody
standing on your chest
and um that just makes you human you
just have this huge horrible thing
you're going through
and it's just real and and what our
friend dr john deloney would call trauma
and it really really is and so give
yourself some space if it takes you a
year to do nothing and make make out a
life that makes you boring and bored
and then you can just sit and
heal and give yourself some room without
push and pull without
striving towards some goal
or something so you're a pretty
goal-oriented person you like to have a
plan and execute the plan so you're
gonna wander your way back to that
pretty quick as soon as your
psyche is healed enough to allow you to
do that but give yourself a little room
to cry
is that okay
yeah i think so i mean it is kind of my
plan to i'm probably yeah 15 acres for
just myself it was never meant to be
just for me it actually made me quite
angry um there you go guess i'm in that
phase of grief right now but yeah i'm
just showing i'm like well if i meet
somebody soon then yeah but you don't
want to live there with somebody and
you're not going to meet me right
it's too soon yeah it's too soon right
now you're still just you're still just
your head's spinning
so give yourself a little hang him out
and and get rid of him out of the
picture because that's what i need to do
but then he needs to go away he'll kind
of keep the house for a handful of
months or just listen on the market
right now put it on the market right now
i wouldn't go refinance it i wouldn't go
the expense of refinancing it he can
wait to get paid out when the house
sells and guess what it'll sell in 20
minutes
if
if i uh go ahead and refinance it he's
agreed to take 90 but if i just sell it
then he'll try and take half of the
equity because he would be owed that
um well i think this is a negotiation
i think this is a negotiation with a
philanderer
i think you punch his lights out and get
him to take 90 and you sell the house
absolutely right
he deserves nothing
hold his feet to the lawyer would say
otherwise i don't give a crap what his
lawyer says this is a negotiation
everything's a negotiation you want your
90 i'm putting the house on the market
you're going to get your 90. as you're
going to get it as soon as you would if
i refinance it i'm not going to go to
the refinance cost you're going to take
your 90. you're going to walk away with
your girlfriend and you're going to kiss
my butt
and this is the negotiation
i hope your lawyer's mean
oh she is good yeah
yeah i don't have it in me right now i
usually can be but i don't have it well
i don't want you to have to fight and
tell your lawyer to go sick them skid
them yeah yeah and if you have to
refinance it to cut it way down if they
you lose the negotiation fine go do it
but you're just losing the refinance
costs because you're going to turn
around pay the stupid mortgage off in 30
days anyway because you're putting house
on the market now
right now it just seems like a lot to
try and because it will sell i would say
in a couple three months max because it
is a high amount and a big portion of
land which a lot of people don't want to
take care of but no it's it's a premium
real estate market
it's going to sell in 20 minutes
put it on the
to like do it that quickly because it's
like
you know um
clean up your life
clean up your life as soon as you can
as quickly as you can simplify
everything and give yourself some room
to grieve
that this guy did you and he mis
mistreated you
i'm so sorry
it's horrible just horrible
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
common sense
for your
dollars and cents
david and marla are with us in hartford
connecticut
says on my screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you so much
very cool how much have you paid off
we have paid off 88 000
in 22 months 88 000 11 really that 11
counts for something right that's big
big difference big difference 88 and 22
months and your range of income during
that two years is what
when we started just about a hundred
thousand and now we're just over 119 000
excellent what do you guys do for a
living
so i'm a school bus driver in a little
farm town in ellington connecticut cool
i work for a insurance company
okay cool growing up for auto auto
insurance so oh good very good what kind
of debt was your 88 000
it was all the bad kind
credit cards a car loan personal loan
and a family loan
oh
what kind of family loan
uh so my husband's parents helped us out
when we were first buying our condo when
we were getting married
and lent us some money and we've paid
them back
that feels good it feels real good
yeah it's better to eat thanksgiving
dinner with somebody you don't owe money
to
amen
uh thanksgiving dinner tastes different
when you eat with your master
oh my goodness
yeah well congratulations you guys okay
what happened what started you on this
ramsay journey 22 months ago
yeah so i used to do our budget and i
was really good at making it but i was
really bad at sticking to it and we were
you know making more and more money but
still living paycheck to paycheck
because i was constantly overspending i
am like the major free spirit of our
family david is the nerd
and uh you know we were doing all the
dance of that transferring credit card
balances back and forth and we'd accrue
more debt because of transfer fees and
i was racking up tons of credit card
debt because i was really living like we
were millionaires but um we weren't and
uh
i was paying for things with a lot of
money that we didn't have and i did i
feel like i did the cardinal sin i was
using our credit card to take cash out
of the atm at one point oh my gosh
i know i know and uh so one day we were
at church and um our executive pastor
andrew was teaching us about biblical
budgeting
and he mentioned financial peace
university that was being taught at our
church and um
after that service we went home we had a
really really hard conversation you know
it wasn't it wasn't a secret that we
were buried in debt but to like kind of
lay it all out there it was really
really hard really humbling and
thankfully you know god showed up my
husband
could have
probably you know laid in to me about
how it was my fault but he just you know
he kind of was like well it's my fault
too you know i knew what's going on we
didn't really do anything to stop it and
he wasn't helping he dumped it on me
exactly exactly and so uh you know lots
of tears on my end but lots of grace on
his end so i'm so grateful um so we
decided to sign up for the class and we
took the class that was 22 months ago we
literally like dove in head first never
looked back and um you know my dave has
been listening to you dave for years
like years and years and years and i was
the one that was not on board so once i
got on board i think it was a relief to
my husband and
we just never looked back you know and
then and we just got really gazelle
intense and
here we are
wow
very cool awesome so you go through the
class and you you were at the point it
sounds like that uh marla from trying to
carry it and juggle it all by yourselves
you were at a point of surrender and
david's at a point like hey we got to
get together we got to do this and so
both of you were ready to completely you
didn't do ish you didn't do anything you
just stepped in did the whole thing
exactly like we teach and you had great
results
absolutely 100 percent
yeah enough was enough we were ready way
to go you guys all right so you're going
through you're we're proud of you you're
excellent you're incredible so we're
going through you're going through the
thing in the class
and little light bulbs are coming on uh
what was the thing that you heard that
you went
oh man
where was that 10 years ago i need to do
that
oh my gosh i mean it was everything
honestly it was everything i believed
every lie about money that there is out
there i believe that we have to have
debt oh everybody has a credit card
payment everybody has a car payment you
know oh debt is just a part of life so
yeah that there that there's such thing
as good debt and all that so
we uh once we heard you know oh no
that's not yeah normal is weird you
don't want to be normal
you know it's not normal to you don't
have to live that way that for me was a
big light bulb moment like wait a minute
we don't have to have a credit score oh
that's that's not true oh okay
and then it was like okay now i just
want to get zero credit score i want to
do that
so i love this
marley you are you may be the most
enthusiastic person that i've talked to
in a long time it is very infectious no
it's wonderful so okay you clearly all
the light bulbs is what you told dave
everything was a light bulb so now i
want to know okay you go out of the
class now we gotta go home
and david you've been following dave for
a long time so none of this is new to
you marla's light bulbs are flashing
like crazy what was the hardest part
about getting this thing started or was
there a moment where it was really
really tough or was it just all in the
whole time and it didn't matter how hard
it was you guys were just
gazelle intense with no struggle i want
to know what it was like
the tough one was for our son the saying
no to things
but i would say
besides that the
holding back and i told you so and just
working together and just getting it
taken care of
yeah definitely
definitely also you know just for me a
really hard part was waiting like the
patience of getting through the baby
step like the baby step one baby step
two i just like i wanted it so badly so
i know maybe that's like contradictory
that it's kind of a good and a bad but
like the closer we got the more i wanted
it you know
and um
yeah definitely it was just you know for
me it was the best craziest part was
taking all that stress off you know
are we going to have enough money to buy
groceries this week or do i have to wait
to pay the mortgage or you know and we
only have one son so
you know our son lincoln he's 10 and
like david said saying no to him
was tough and he he was like i hate the
dave ramsey
there it is
he's like every time my husband would
listen to dave ramsey like turn that off
so that was tough but totally worth it
and you know we're not done yet you know
we're we're just we're still going we're
still super psyched that's awesome well
you ruined his life and you saved his
life at the same time exactly
that's so fabulous well done you guys we
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
because that's the next chapter in your
story you're going to be baby steps
millionaires now you're on your way
you're on the way well well done you
guys well done thank you excellent
excellent work also a copy of total
money makeover for you uh that's the
next uh that way you got something to
give away and ruin some other little
kid's life out there that'll be great
exactly i can't wait to do that
very fun all right david and marla
hartford connecticut 88 000 paid off in
22 months making 100 to 119. count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
barlow went up high there that was
another option
go big or go home in hartford
i like it
[Applause]
dogs are howling everywhere in hartford
connecticut on that last note that was
true passion there
so good
oh man hey here's the thing when you
find something that works and it's
proven
and just like your new book paycheck to
purpose the
clear
path to doing work you love you want to
find a new position you want to find a
new career you want to get out of debt
and become wealthy these clear paths
this detailed step-by-step plan that's
proven um
it is how transformation works in our
world that's right you don't transform
just
like a genie in a bottle like you said
earlier
there's no genie out there no there's no
pill you can take to get out of debt or
have the job you love you have to go
through the transformational process the
steps
and it works when you do it way to go
financial peace university proud of you
guys david and marla they love you this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today luke 16 10 and 11
whoever can be trusted with very little
can also be trusted with much and
whoever is dishonest with very little
will also be dishonest with much
so if you've not been trustworthy in
handling worldly wealth who will trust
you with true riches
general norman schwarzkopf said the
truth of the matter is that you always
know the right thing to do
the hard part
is doing it
yeah that's kind of what this whole
show's about we answer questions they
already know the answer to
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
rebecca's in jacksonville florida hi
rebecca how are you
well hello mr david
[Applause]
i
oh my gosh i can't believe i'm talking
to you
okay
pull myself together it's all right
rebecca breathe there you go oh you got
through kiddo you got through okay how
can we help yes sir well um so i have a
bit of a
fun story i guess um
i my husband and i uh we're 26 years old
we have two children two beautiful girls
and whenever my husband got out of high
school he bought this house that we're
living in and
it's right across the street from my
mother-in-law um so
you know things were okay but this
beginning of the past past year
um
my father-in-law
he um he got really sick and
no one knew about it until day four
when uh my mother-in-law called and said
hey um you know larry's not doing really
well and so my husband went over and
checked on him and
lo and behold he was really really sick
he was dehydrated
and he was he was not given any like
nutrition for four days he she was just
giving him like ibuprofen she didn't
really know what to do i would say i was
trying to give her the benefit of the
doubt but um whenever my husband walked
into the house it was like extreme
hoarder
um addition no airflow to the room and
all that kind of stuff so he went to the
hospital and i just said you know what
and i put my mama pants on and i said
she's not allowed to take care of him
i'm gonna i'm gonna do this and i knew
that he couldn't go back to the house
and my husband and i we just looked at
each other and we said this is why we
have an emergency fund because it's an
emergency and we don't want him to pass
away he's 82.
um so
four or five days later after the er the
doctors are like hey he's not doing well
say goodbye and we're like no no no no
so we took him home we gave him sunshine
he had coveted and everything gave him
sunshine gave him you know just just
pursued god's you know what what god
tells us to do with our bodies and just
try to pump him with vitamins and
everything and he got better like uh the
rebecca that's better we're going to run
out of time honey
how can we help
how can we
help me
um we have an opportunity to buy a house
that's why it's worth more than what
she's asking but it's a fixer-upper um
so um
i know
so i'm just i'm sick and tired of being
so close to my mother-in-law and my
father-in-law and it's not sick and
tired it's just like i just don't you
moved your father-in-law in with you
he we did and also we got him back
that's the definition of living close to
him
yes sir
did you send me back
we did we sent him back after he got
well
so he's back down at the harder house
now
yeah and it was by choice and we try to
we really tried to just like
change everything but you can't change
it okay so you're you're not responsible
for what happens across the street
you're responsible for what happens in
your house so they're not bothering you
we figured that out no they're not
bothering you so why do you need to move
good question um
it's just i guess the whole
it's just
you know whenever they pass when when
she passes by it's always
a stop and kind of
embarrassing like yelling or
or uh demanding like to see her
grandchildren and and it it could be
more casual or it could be more like
you know set times but there's no
boundary lines i guess and we have to
constantly put them in place
and like um so she's like standing in
the street yelling at your house
sometimes yeah yeah and it's um it's not
it's not always that bad but it's just
for me i guess how old is she um
uh 63 and he's 80
um
[Music]
so what is your husband what does your
husband say
he
he he tries it's his mom so i know what
does he say about moving
oh he wants to do it we found an awesome
deal and we just don't know if we should
sell our house why not
move okay
okay
i mean i got a crazy woman standing in
the street yelling at my house yeah i'd
have a son in the yard looking for i
mean even if i'm not ken to her i'm
looking for a new place
that's a true especially if i'm kin to
her it's like doubles the move yeah
rebecca yes
i don't know what you're afraid of but
make a good financial decision but yeah
it's good for your family i mean you
guys
there's a lot going on here that we
don't have dr john here to help us with
so um yeah there's boundary issues
there's all kinds of stuff there's
strange strange hoarders and yeah if it
happened to the old guy once it's
probably gonna happen again yeah it's
like yeah but you can still move him
into the house at the country too and
then she'll be by herself standing in
the street yelling at herself i guess i
don't know
yeah i'm moving yes
as long as you can afford to make the
move and i don't use this as an excuse
to do something financially stupid but
if you've got a lateral move or a move
you can afford to make let's go ahead
and make it michael's in dallas hey
michael welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave how are you guys today great how
can we help
so this is more of a ken question i
guess it's not so much a money question
um i was listening to the show a couple
weeks ago when him and um george were
filling in for you
and he made a comment about his job and
how much he loved it and how he kind of
felt bad for
you know someone that might be sitting
there listening digging a ditch right
now and actually that was me um
i've been wanting to change careers you
were actually digging
oh yeah well with an excavator i do i do
yeah i was actually talking about the
old school shovel but the excavator
sounds kind of fun to me to be honest
with you but i get the point well it is
it it's fun it um it gets monotonous at
times when you do it 60 70 hours a week
right you know every every little young
man loves heavy equipment doesn't really
have to do it for the rest of their
career so right
um
my wife currently makes 90k um we're i'm
24 she's 23.
we have little to no debt i have a truck
that's about to be paid off okay so i'm
i'm wanting to
just try and figure out what suits me
best i actually took your career
assessment i bought the new book okay in
the bundle and i'm gonna read it good
all right so so when you got your
purpose statement and you read your
purpose statement back
uh what ideas started flowing through
your minds did it confirm some things
that it opened up new questions
a little bit of both yes so i've always
been more empathetic i guess and more
passionate about current events and
what's going on in the world and
you know um what do you wonder about
michael but you're unsure how to get
there or if it maybe see is it bad pizza
i know you've got an idea i can hear it
what's the idea that you're not sure
about but you'd do it if you knew there
was no risk and you didn't have to
commit to it
yeah so i mean if there was if i woke up
today and i could be anybody i wanted to
be um i would i guess for me to feel
like i'm
making a difference something that you
know really
would feel good to me to wake up and do
every day would be something along the
lines of politics whether it be state
and local government that's actually the
number two thing that your assessment
gave me but um okay you know either
something entrepreneurship i just
the day in day out i get it
right so so here's what we got to do
we've got two really good options our
time is limited michael so i'm gonna do
this really quick okay you've got two
viable options entrepreneurship and what
you've got to do is say if i could start
a business today what would who would be
the people i'd want to help what's the
problem the business would be solving
and what's the solution that i would be
providing through this business that
would solve that problem that's a good
little three-question exercise and see
what business ideas come up political
peace more than politicians i think so
and i think you ought to look at what
are some avenues for me not an elected
office to get into the political system
local state government i've got some
experience i've got relationships what
would that look like we've got to start
to look and as we begin to dig michael
now we're going to see oh i could get
there
i want to get there that's what we got
to do the new book is from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to doing work you
love it comes out today
go get it ken good show
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you